here blue on the street yes
learn dialect at school yes
because we haven't actually learned that anymore
to our children
a lot of strokes and dialects are disappearing
I just think that's a shame
maybe someday become prime minister
yes I will not close the door forever
I think that is 1 bit exaggerated
do not legalize
yes free public transportation yes
space for the wolf no
keti koti 1 national holiday no
but there is 1 nuance in it
because I am not necessarily against it
but I think we will also have Liberation Day
May 5 also have to make 1 national holiday
yes nuclear energy yes
Lelystad airport open no
narrow the pay gap between men and women
military service for young people no
130 on the highway yes
in Every village 1 ATM yes
1 asylum quota yes